Film Courage: You talked about something in
your book and that’s the magic of making
people feel special.
And I think we all think we do this ‘the
right way,’ but we probably don’t.
So what are some of the ways (aside from complimenting
people, which I think that’s great), but
how can we show this either verbally or non-verbally?
Carole Kirschner: There are a couple of different
ways, one is actually by listening.
Most people…I won’t say most people…many
people don’t listen.
When you are having a conversation with them,
it’s a monologue.
“Let me tell you about me.
Let me tell you about what I did.
Let me tell you about my kid.
Let me tell you about my project.
Let me tell you…”
If you actually, actively listen to somebody,
they feel seen and heard and appreciated.
I’m a big fan of gifts, nothing over the
top but I taught my daughter (who went into
be an intern) on the first day you bring snacks,
you know what I mean?
You bring cookies or muffins or something
else.
Or afterwards you send something to thank
people.
You thank people genuinely and sincerely for
giving their time because in this business
that is in short supply.
So thanking people in a genuine way, not an
a-kissy way, sending a little something is
really nice to do and listening to people.
Helping people, finding a way that you can
help somebody.
That’s huge.
That is how you make somebody feel special.
Film Courage: When you do want to thank somebody,
is it a text message, is it via social media?
Do you Tweet them “Hey, just want to say
thank you, Carole!”
Or is it an actual email or a card?
Carole Kirschner: If you’re thanking somebody
who is under 25, it can be a text if you happen
to know their cell number.
I’m not sure why you know their cell number,
but if you happen to it can be a text.
It could be a private Tweet.
I personally think it should be an email to
them and it should be within 24 hours and
it should be a paragraph or less.
And if you’ve met with somebody who’s
old school, send a card but don’t have kittens
on that card.
Don’t have anything too cute on that card.
Just your initial or a thank you, very simple.
And I think that works, too.
I think you really have to decide who you’re
sending it to.